a new poll from the university of
virginia shows that huge swaths of
americans despise each other but does
that matter plus anthony faucit
continues to preach utter panic and the
democrats stumble toward an agreement on
blowout spending i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment here is your morning report on
inflation inflation's already running
hot you know this and now the democrats
of course are attempting to agree on 3.5
trillion dollars maybe 2 trillion maybe
1.5 trillion but just more money into
the system here's the deal if you think
money grows on trees then you can just
keep living in ignorance if not then you
probably should take some of your asset
base and diversify it into something
like precious metals if you haven't
reached out to birch gold to diversify
part of your ira or 401k into a precious
metals ira do it today text ben 247 4747
get a free information kit on protecting
your savings with gold i buy my gold
from birch gold they have an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star views thousands of
happy customers in this month when you
place an order with birch gold you will
get a signed copy of my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps text
ben to 47 47 47 to claim your free no
obligation information kit on holding
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account plus sending this text is the
only way to be eligible for a signed
copy of my book when you place an order
it's a pretty good deal again text ben
to 47 47 47 protect your savings today
with my friends over at birch gold
already it's very difficult to look at
the current political situation in the
united states and not see that the
country seems to be falling apart
there's been a lot of reasons that have
been proposed for this in the right side
of history my book from a couple of
years ago i proposed that essentially we
had lost a lot of common threads that
bound us together in the social fabric
we'd lost a lot of the institutions
churches no longer have the same pull
that they once did social organizations
no longer have the same pull that they
once did and we don't have the same sort
of foundational principles and we need
to rebuild those foundational principles
and then there are those who have
suggested that it's due to purely obama
or purely due to trump or maybe it's
just due to the fact that capitalism has
isolated us right that's the argument of
both the left and sort of the
nationalist populist movement there are
a lot of answers that have been provided
but one thing is pretty clear to
everyone and that is political
polarization is now at a modern high and
we've not been this polarized as a
society since at least the 1960s and
maybe more so since the 1960s which
would mean that we haven't been
polarized probably since the civil war
if you actually look at it statistically
in terms of how many americans really
really really despise each other and
that is what a new poll out of the
university of virginia center for
politics says according to the
politics the new poll shows the
majorities of both trump and biden
voters express support for several
different elements of the bipartisan
infrastructure and reconciliation bills
being debated in congress but more
importantly majorities often large
majorities of both biden and trump
voters express some form of distrust for
voters elected officials and media
sources they associate with the other
side a strong majority of trump voters
see no real difference between democrats
and socialists a strong majority of
biden voters at least somewhat agree
that there is no difference between
republicans and fascists
that's sort of a problem okay so the
reality is that many of the things that
the democrats are proposing are not
necessarily socialists they're just big
spending social democrat kind of stuff
from northern europe that is not quite
the same thing as complete
nationalization of all resources social
democracy essentially posits that
capitalism ought to provide the basis
for the economy but that we ought to
redistribute a lot of the gains of
capitalism and in certain areas we ought
to nationalize right in certain areas
they are socialistic in certain areas
they are not it's sort of a sliding
scale in other words but the notion that
democrats are like full out nationalize
all industry socialists that's true for
some of them like bernie sanders but it
probably isn't true for the majority of
democrats who at least pay lip service
to the notion that you have a right to
private property and that you should
enjoy most of your rights to private
property and most i would say democrats
other than the squad
are still in line with the notion you
should be able to own a business and you
should be able to reap the benefits of
that business at least to a certain
extent and the arguments are over to
what extent and how strong the
regulation should be now the momentum
inside the democratic party is certainly
toward the far left there's no question
about that and the continuous growth of
regulation and government has has drawn
us ever closer to as frederick would say
the road to serfdom but that does not
mean that all democrats particularly
democratic voters many democratic
politicians maybe most democratic voters
are not socialists and for those on the
left who think that all republicans are
fascists again
you'd have to point to who you think is
a fascist on the right side of the aisle
like an out and out fascist
okay so what the poll shows is that
policy-wise there's some commonality
between trump and biden voters but
people look at each other and they
really hate each other which suggests
that more than anything else this is a
culture war this really has less to do
with policy than it has to do with
culture and this is something that i've
been saying for a long time when you
have some of the country that believes
the other half of the country is a bunch
of religious rubes who are obsessed with
their sex lives and who want to control
all aspects of their boudoir
those people tend to treat other people
with a lot of disdain and that's what
you see with the barack obama bitter
clingers comments from 2008 or the
hillary clinton deplorables comments
from 2016 that there's just this wide
swath of evil racist xenophobic
americans who live in the middle of the
country and they're really really
terrible awful people
and then on the right you have people
saying well if those people look at me
like that well i don't want to hang out
with those people at all
and there is somewhat of an imbalance in
terms of what people think the true
threat to the country is and that
imbalance is now kind of moving into
balance what i mean by that
is that if you look at a poll a couple
years ago from my friend kristen sultan
sanderson what it showed is that
democrats believe the number one threat
to america
is not an economic threat it's not a
foreign policy threat it's trump voters
and you're starting to see trump voters
respond by saying okay well if you
perceive me as a threat this now makes
you a threat to me and so what this poll
shows is that a huge percentage of
americans on both sides of the aisle
really don't like people on the other
side of the aisle so to the statement
i've come to view elected officials from
the opposing party as presenting a clear
and present danger to american democracy
80 of biden voters at least somewhat
agree that elected officials from the
republican party present a clear and
present danger to american democracy 84
of trump voters feel the same way
are you concerned that you or someone
close to you might experience personal
loss or suffering due to the effects of
the opposing party eighty percent of
biden voters say yes eighty-two percent
of trump voters say yes
despite the us constitution's first
amendment protection of free speech some
media sources on the extreme left or
right have become so untruthful they
should be censored 78 of democrats say
at least they have some sympathy for the
idea of censorship some 73 percent of
republicans say the same about left-wing
sources
of democrats say that they want to that
republicans want to eliminate the
influence of progressive values in
american life and culture 87 percent of
republicans feel the same way about
democrats
some 77 percent of democrats say that
the mainstream media might as well be a
part of the republican party 77 of
democrats believe the media is biased
toward the republican party which is
totally crazy
of republicans believe that the
mainstream media is part of the
democratic party which is significantly
more accurate
and of course 56
of democrats believe there's no real
difference between republicans and
fascists 76 percent of republicans
believe there's no difference between
democrats and socialists now again i'm
not going to pretend that there is a
complete equation here because there is
not the democrats are much warmer
towards socialism than the republicans
are toward fascism there's just no
question about this it's on a on a base
route level the democratic party has a
lot more crossover with socialistic
ideas about redistribution of income for
example or restrictions placed on use of
private property or even the family than
republicans have with the idea that
there ought to be complete top down
control of government in every aspect of
your life which is really the essence of
fascism
fascism tends more toward the left in
that particular iteration but it's very
clear that americans bottom line here
are polarized and see people on the
other side of the political aisle as a
real threat to them
now in a second we're going to ask the
question whether that matters because i
think everybody sees that and they go
okay well that's why the country is
falling apart but there's some new data
suggesting that's not really why the
country is falling apart and it's kind
of fascinating and worth going into
because all of this is root level stuff
in american politics what's driving
the polarization what's driving the fact
that people are having these fraught
battles over sometimes very fringe
issues like what's driving all that
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let's talk about a simple
fact of life you need home and auto
insurance you do now you need both of
those things in most states you're
actually mandated to have home and auto
insurance but you're probably paying too
much for those things because in all
likelihood you probably haven't thought
about pairing them you just did it via
word of mouth policy genius makes it
easy to compare home and auto insurance
all in one place they can help you find
home and auto coverage similar to what
you have now but at a lower price
they've saved customers an average of
1250 per year over what they were paying
for home and auto insurance
their team will handle the paperwork to
set up your new policy or switch you
over from your current one getting
started is super simple first you head
on over to policygenius.com shapiro home
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property then policy
genius takes it from there they'll
compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate
and find you your lowest quotes the
policy genius team can look for ways to
save you more including bundling your
home and auto policies and if they find
you better right than what you're paying
now they'll switch you over for free
their top notch service has earned
policy genius thousands of five star
reviews across trustpilot and google so
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
home to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and very important to get it right
okay so we see this poll from university
of virginia and it shows again massive
polarization in the american public
democrats think republicans are fascists
republicans think democrats are
socialists and all the rest so the
question is
what sort of difference does this make
in our politics now the rote answer is
huge difference right if we don't like
each other it's going to be very
difficult for us to live together
however there is a new study that is out
from
quoted by thomas edsel who does a really
interesting column for the new york
times i know there really is an
interesting columnist at the new york
times
and he quotes a study
titled political sectarianism in america
published by 15 important scholars in
science magazine in november 2020.
the science essay argued the political
sectarianism of the public incentivizes
politicians to adopt anti-democratic
tactics when pursuing electoral or
political victories a recent experiment
shows that today a majority party
candidate in most u.s house districts
democrat or republican could get elected
despite openly violating democratic
principles like electoral fairness
checks and balances or civil liberties
right there's a study from last year
suggesting that most americans are
electing people who don't really care
about the checks and balances of
american life
however david brookman joshua kala and
sean westwood political sciences at
berkeley yale and dartmouth challenged
that science magazine article instead
they make the case in their december
2020 paper does effective polarization
undermine democratic norms or
accountability maybe not that partisan
hostility may be destructive but
attempts to moderate it will not
diminish party loyalty or tolerance for
anti-democratic changes in election law
or the decline in political
accountability in other words
it's true that partisan hostility may be
bad but even if we got rid of partisan
hostility that actually would not solve
the underlying problem which is that
many many many americans of all stripes
seem to be willing to use the government
as a club to cudgel somebody else
brookman and his co-authors agree with a
lot of the prior research that found
that effective polarization has been
growing worldwide but what they differ
with is those who take the growing
partisan hostility argument a step
further to contend that if citizens were
less effectively polarized they would be
less likely to endorse norm violation
overlook co-partisan politicians
shortcomings oppose compromise adopt
their party's views or misperceive
economic conditions
in other words this really is not being
driven by polarization the polarization
is being driven in turn by something
else
and brookman and his co-authors write
quote we find no evidence
that an exogenous decrease in effective
polarization causes a downstream
decrease in opposition to democratic
norms in other words even if we get less
polarized people still don't like
democracy anymore
we investigate the causal effects of
effective polarization on a variety of
downstream incomes in five political
domains electoral accountability
adopting one parties policy positions
support for legislative bipartisanship
support for democratic norms and
perception of objective conditions
so in other words it seems like
reducing polarization between people
making people feel better about one
another is not necessarily the answer to
the real political problem that we have
right now which is the subjection of our
political norms to withering fire
there's another article from may 2021
from a sociologist at stanford named jan
volkl and eight colleagues
in which they write there is widespread
concern that rising effective
polarization disliked from members of
the opposing party is exacerbating a
range of anti-democratic attitudes
accordingly scholars and practitioners
alike have invested great effort in
developing depolarization interventions
and successfully promising interventions
that have been have been identified that
successfully reduce effective
polarization
these efforts have mixed results we find
that the depolarization interventions
reliably reduce effective polarization
but this reduction does not reliably
translate into reduced support for
undemocratic practices on democratic
candidates or partisan violence
they conclude our findings suggest
effective polarization may not be as
problematic for democratic societies as
is widely assumed
in some the research shows interventions
can reduce both attitudinal and
behavioral indicators of effective
polarization without reducing
anti-democratic attitudes so people
could still be anti-democracy even while
they kind of like their neighbors as it
turns out this calls into question the
commonly held assumptions that
anti-democratic attitudes are downstream
consequences of effective polarization
this is really
quite fascinating research and suggests
something deeper has been going on here
so what is the deeper thing right if you
don't dislike your neighbors then why
are so many of us abandoning democratic
norms why are so many people abandoning
for example checks and balances which is
clearly happening right more and more
americans on both sides of the aisle
seem to look at federalism and say well
yeah but if we can grab the brass ring
if we can grab the top of government why
shouldn't we use that to cram down our
perspectives on a multiplicity of other
americans now the normal explanation
might be yeah i disagree with those
other americans so much and they're such
a threat to me that i need to use the
brass ring to cram down my policies to
prevent them from threatening me right
it's a battle for all right this is a
war over the government gun and if they
get it they're gonna shoot us and if we
get it we better shoot them
so that would be the suggestion that has
been made before that polarization is
what is driving the anti-democratic
tendencies and these new studies are
suggesting no that's not correct that
even if the differences are somewhat
relatively minor
people are still willing to grab the
government gun and use them to cram down
their own political points of view
in just one second we'll get to why i
think this is happening first let's talk
about the reality of sleep you need a
great night's sleep and you know if you
don't have the right bed stuff it's not
going to help now you get in bed and
you're sleeping too hot or sleeping too
cold it's just uncomfortable well you
need my pillow my pillow wants to give
back to listeners you can get great
discounts on all my pillow products if
you go to mypillow.com right now and
click on that radio listeners special
get deep discounts on my pillow mattress
toppers towels and so much more for
example my pillow is offering a buy one
get one free offer on giza sheets these
are top quality sheets you will love all
my pillow products come with a 60 day
money back guarantee and a 10 year
warranty go to mypillow.com click on the
radio listener specials for the buy one
get one free offer on the giza sheets
and use promo code daily wire at
checkout or call
800-651-1148 you'll also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including pillow slippers and the my
pillow mattress stopper and my pillow
towel sets that's mypillow.com enter
code dailywire or call 1-800-651-1148
tell them dailywire sent you that's
1-800-651-1148 these are great deals on
fantastic products for my pillow go
check them out right now the deals won't
last forever give them a call right now
or go to mypillow.com and enter daily
wire okay so why is it that if what's
causing all of this movement away from
checks and balances and democratic norms
and respect for outcomes if what's
driving that is not effective
polarization right how much we feel
threatened by each other what is driving
that
the answer is i think a broad
perspective shift
on human nature that has happened in the
united states and across its parties
though not to equal extent
and a broad shift in what we think the
government was constructed for i think
people no longer understand why the
united states government was constructed
the way it was
and the united states government was
constructed the way that it was by the
founding fathers because they had a
certain perception of human nature that
perception of human nature is that human
beings were inherently limited
human beings had a great capacity for
reason sure but they also human beings
had the unfortunate tendency to be venal
and self-serving and extraordinarily
ambitious
and to grab the brass ring the human
tendency was to grab the brass ring and
then to use that power against somebody
else
right that was the human tendency and if
you wish to share a polity with other
people regardless of who the other
people are whether you like them or that
you don't like them
you're going to have to restrict your
own ability to use power to do what is
good see here's the thing there are two
ways to view power and there are flip
sides of the same coin one way is that
you are grabbing power in order to do
something good
and this has been how most fascists
throughout history have justified what
they're doing they're doing something
good now the flip side of that is the
people who get the raw end of the deal
the people with the short end of the
stick to them when somebody says i'm
grabbing power to do something good very
often what that means is you're grabbing
power to do something bad to me right
you want to do something good for your
friends something good on behalf of
quote unquote society but for me
individually that's a bad thing that the
use of power inherently means that there
is somebody who is going to be the
target of the power
and so if you are grabbing power
inherently somebody else is going to be
worse off power is in fact a zero-sum
game
and there are very rare circumstances in
which power is not a zero-sum game
but in most political circumstances
power is a zero-sum game
it's only not a zero-sum game when you
have like overt aggression right this is
why the sort of libertarian perspective
on government is the government ought to
be used only in order to maintain
certain basic legal norms certain or to
prevent violence for example because
that is a a non-zero-sum game right if
there's no violence for anybody we all
have better lives
including the people who theoretically
would be doing violence and then would
be the victim of somebody else doing
violence to them but for most of of the
things that we do as a government
somebody is going to get the short end
of the stick somebody is going to pay
the price somebody's going to foot the
bill
so what the founder said is if that's
the case then we better have
overwhelming support for anything that
we do as a federal government
particularly in order for us to make a
move right we would have subsidiary at
very local levels where you and your
friends really agree on a lot of stuff
well then you have more ability as a
local government to do what it is that
you want because everybody else who
doesn't want to live there can simply
move right if you have a very local
community you know everybody in the town
everybody in the town knows you you want
to preserve your way of life well then
you have a little bit more power under
the federal constitution you know
barring sort of certain fundamental
violations of rights like
fascistic non-voting right the the
federal government does guarantee to the
state's republican form of government
but barring extraordinarily basic rights
violations local governments can do a
lot of stuff
and then as you kind of move out as you
zoom out from the very local level to
the broader and broader level the
federal government was supposed to do
less and less because we agree on less
and less and so in order for us to do
anything we need to overcome a bunch of
obstacles and burdens in order to prove
that what we were doing was so vastly
important that it was worthy of the use
of power
and so this again springs from a vision
of human nature that the founders were
grounding in both a judeo-christian
value system which suggests that man is
inherently sinful and that man is
inherently flawed and that man also has
the capacity to be
an angel but also the capacity to be a
devil right i mean this is directly from
federalist 51 where james madison talks
about the capacity of man to be both
angel and devil the notion was that
if men were angels no government would
be necessary and if angel and men were
devils no government would be sufficient
okay so there was that view of human
nature and then over time it seems that
the view of human nature itself shifted
and in accordance with that the view of
government shifted so in the late 19th
century mid to late 19th century there's
this movement away from a vision of
human nature as bounded to a view of
human nature as unbounded completely
malleable
that that all human limits were
essentially products of their
environment and if we could just shift
the environment in any direction then
human nature would inherently change
this is one of the key components of
marxism is that human nature would
change as the economic system under
which we live changed
inevitably
and that was the the kind of vision of
the progressive view of the united
states in the early 20th century if we
can just shift the circumstances under
which people live we will create a
better form of human being there is an
innate malleability to human beings and
therefore human beings could be angels
and if human beings could be angels why
would you have to fear the government
why would you have to fear a vast broad
national government doing exactly what
it is that it wanted to do why would you
need democracy anymore you just like
really there would be no need for voting
all you would need is the right person
at the top and if that right person at
the top was doing the right thing well
then liberty would be of no consequence
because liberty of course
we all pay homage to liberty liberty
only exists when liberty means that
something you disagree with is allowed
to happen
if you believe that liberty only extends
to the things you want to happen that's
not actual liberty
right that's that's just you being your
own little dictator
and the notion of liberty is that
liberty allows for innovation liberty
allows for experimentation liberty
allows for the possibility of pluralism
as a as
the famous philosopher
isaiah berlin used to say
and the the the basic notion here is
that liberty was not only a tool but it
was a virtue
so the the
the core of liberty is disagreement the
core of liberty is that you don't have
all the answers we don't know all of the
most virtuous things that yes there are
certain baseline things that we all sort
of agree are virtuous and those can be
encoded in law
now as a society we've broken down even
those things right the argument against
liberty is that liberty has become
libertarian libertarianism and this is
the argument from the right is that
liberty went so far that it basically
tore down all the institutions that we
all used to agree upon and now we have
nothing we agree upon and so we're all
falling apart so in st in order to
reinstill a sense of commonality we need
to use the power of government that's
the argument from the right
but that's the polarization argument
okay the the real argument that i'm
suggesting is more kind of broadly based
than that argument there's some virtue
to that argument although the virtues
don't go all that far because the
reality is that aside from kind of
resetting very very basic notions of
virtue and american life and those
virtues really are sort of relegated to
the amendments that that
are made to the constitution of the
united states and the bill of rights
that aside from from those specific
virtues
the government should not really be
involved
what most people have fallen into is
this idea that the government itself is
our friend the government is quote
unquote us as barack obama suggested in
2012. well the founders never thought
the government was us we're individuals
we're families we're local communities
the government is not us but here's the
thing the minute that we as a society i
mean like pretty much everyone across
the aisle decides that the federal
government is the answer to all of our
problems
all of our questions
and the federal government ought to be
the power doing the virtuous thing not
preserving liberty not preserving the
possibility of other people disagreeing
not pursuing subsidiarity
once that happens the polarization
doesn't matter anymore all you want is
the right person in charge of the
government and this is going to lead to
an enormous amount of inherent
dissatisfaction because here's the thing
all of that's a lie it doesn't matter
who's at the top of government it's
never going to be the greatest person
it could be the greatest person and it
still wouldn't matter because we would
still have disagreements in this country
the sort of longing for an authoritarian
monarch to lead us forward out of
whatever morass we have found ourselves
in and this exists on nearly all sides
of the political owl is extraordinarily
dangerous but it is an outgrowth of a
failure to understand basic human nature
in the way the founders understood basic
human nature they believed in checks and
balances because even they were blessed
with some of the great leadership of all
time and people like george washington
or john adams or thomas jefferson right
even they understood that all these
people are inherently limited and flawed
and you can't give them absolute and
ultimate power we seem to have lost that
capacity to understand innate human flaw
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about a simple
way to keep nausea out of your life you
need to check out relief ban okay so
yesterday went for a test drive with my
kids
and with with somebody in a tesla let me
tell you that that car's astonishingly
good however because if you're not used
to riding in a an electric vehicle it's
really smooth you get really carsick
really easily so i actually brought
along with me relief band because relief
band is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband it has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural relief with zero
side effects for as long as necessary
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through a leaf band it's available to
the masses relief band works by
stimulating a nerve in the wrist it
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick
relief man is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting and if you know
someone who deals with nausea a relief
man does make a great gift i actually
got one for my sister as the world's
opening back up don't let the fear of
nausea keep you on the sidelines right
now relief band has an exclusive offer
just for ben shapiro listeners if you go
to reliefband.com and use promo code
shapiro you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping and no questions asked 30 day
money back guarantees you got nothing to
lose it really does work head on over to
r e l i e f b a and d dot com
reliefband.com use our promo code
shapiro for 20 off plus free shipping go
check that out right now okay so
if your hope if your great hope is that
electing the right people to positions
of power is going to fix everything then
you are likely to be disappointed
you're likely to be disappointed because
this has never been the case it has
never been the case throughout human
history that the person with absolute
power the enlightened monarch
has ever pleased the people in any
serious way where a feedback loop was
possible it was easy to say that they
were a great monarch from the
perspective of history but you never got
a poll of the people they were ruling
and the reality is that checks and
balances were specifically designed in
order to preserve the innovation
possible through liberty in order to
preserve the possibility that perhaps
we're wrong in order to preserve the
epistemic humility that is necessary for
the functioning of a free society
and of course that is that that sort of
humility rests in a belief about the
inherent flaws in human nature when you
get rid of those when you suggest there
really are no inherent flaws in human
nature when individual identity breaks
down
what you get is a desire for power pure
and simple and it doesn't matter that
you disagree with your neighbor only
mildly you are virtuous and your
neighbor has the wrong idea
and it doesn't matter whether democracy
says that one thing or another right
virtue overcomes democracy principle
overcomes democracy now there are
certain cases where principle does
overcome democracy right i mean those
principles are spelled out in the
constitution this is why we have a
constitutional process whereby if
certain legislation violates core
principles it gets struck down and
there's certain things a democracy is
just not allowed to do
again that is because the founders
believed that there were these core
principles that had to be protected even
from the people
but if you're such a believer that human
beings are
essentially at root both completely
malleable and inherently virtuous but
only people who think like you you're
much more likely to be anti-democratic
right you sort of
democracy becomes a tool in your arsenal
when you're a majority you're very
pro-democracy and when you're a minority
you're very anti-democracy and you
believe that you should rule using the
authoritarian state
no matter what anybody else thinks
right we need an aggressive
administrative state to do what we want
without the
weighing in of the american people but
then when the american people agree with
us then the american people should be
allowed to do whatever the hell they
want
this seems to be the perspective
it is very strong on the left it exists
on the right as well
and again it is an outgrowth of a
failure to understand what human nature
is and some of that failure of outgrowth
happened over the course again of two
centuries and now we are seeing the
apotheosis of it as everything becomes
nationalized
right as every issue now affects you
as the way we approach issues is not by
being in contact like here's the thing
when you spend a lot of time outdoors or
with your friends and family at
synagogue or church
yes they're they're wonderful people you
hang out with them and you also think i
really wouldn't want these people to
control my life and i certainly wouldn't
want people far away to control our
lives when you're online all the time
it's easy to find groups of people like
you who are the only virtuous people who
have ever existed in all of history you
can tear down all the old statues you
can remake the world anew all you need
is the power
so as i say i don't think this is about
the polarization primarily i think it is
about the fact that the american people
and westerners generally have shifted
away from a quasi-religious view of
humanity which by the way is more backed
by the science and toward a bizarrely
mystical view of humanity in which you
define yourself inherently you are
completely malleable to the point where
you can actually define your own gender
you can make of yourself whatever you
wish and not only that you are the only
person who has ever been virtuous in the
history of the universe and therefore
democracy doesn't matter
when we say in modern society that yeah
the the democratic principles have to go
by the wayside because there are higher
principles typically what we mean is we
wish to be the person holding the sword
and then it doesn't matter what you
think of the person on the opposing side
like it doesn't the polarization doesn't
help obviously if you think the person
on the other side of the aisle is bad it
makes you feel good about using the
power but even if the other person is
not all that bad
the power is there to be used after all
okay that is really what's affecting our
politics and this is evident in every
area
it's evident wherever you look in
american politics and abroad right now
this attitude
that pluralism democratic processes that
constitutional checks and balances these
things ought not matter because if we
just have a great leader he will lead us
to a better day and in fact if people
disapprove those people need to be run
roughshod over this is the story of
covet demagoguery from the federal
government for example
i don't look at the day when you present
data people get angry because it's
become a referendum on your faith in
government
in some ways covet has become a
referendum on your belief system that
the enlightened few will lead us to a
better day not that every individual has
the capacity to make a decision many of
those decisions will be bad but freedom
is still necessary
right not the idea that free markets
will bear fruit which by the way is the
story of the pandemic yes operation warp
speed protected all of these drug
manufacturers from liability with regard
to if they made a vaccine that didn't
work they'd still get paid by the
federal government but you really think
that if the federal government had not
been pushing
vaccines very very hard that companies
wouldn't have jumped in i mean how many
private companies are attempting to
develop things like oral vaccines
attempting to develop right now
therapeutics that are not being paid for
by operation warp speed for example
okay but instead what has happened is
that and this is perfectly
it used to be less true now it is 100
true with so many treatments that are
now available for covet with the
vaccines that are out there
we should be moving away from the notion
that we need top-down government control
and yet there is this sense that we need
to be told what to do by the greatest
among us
because they will shape the environment
that's around us and help us achieve
perfection help us achieve almost a
certain sort of personal salvation
that's the only way i can explain the
sort of fealty that a lot of people seem
to have for public figures in the health
establishment
so when i say that we have good
treatments what i mean is that there's
good news on covet okay the coveted
surge in the south in the southeast is
over if you look at the numbers from
florida from georgia if you look at
texas all of these numbers are just way
down nobody reports on that because the
media have an interest in pretending
that freedom is coincident with a rise
in covet but right now you look in the
northeast and there's a pretty big spike
in covet because it turns out that this
virus is seasonal and when people go
inside they tend to infect one another
with covid
and
if you're vaccinated you won't die
but if your own vaccine you might die
and even the states that have very high
vaccination rates they don't have 98
vaccination rates and even areas like
israel where they have very high
vaccination rates still a lot of people
are being infected okay with all that
said we have a lot of good things that
prevent hospitalization and death
and we now have this new drug from merck
on friday they said they have an
experimental pill for people sick with
coven
and it had reduced hospitalizations and
deaths by half
if cleared by regulators it would be the
first pill shown to treat covet 19
adding a whole new easy-to-use weapon to
an arsenal that already includes the
vaccine
a decision from the fda could come
within weeks now again it is amazing
that we still have to run through this
ridiculous sideshow that the fda is in
order to delay treatment how many
treatments at this point has the fda
delayed so long that they've
probably allowed tens of thousands of
deaths to happen in the united states
just because of delays inherent in the
fda system
but with that said like we now have good
treatments
we now have we we should be optimistic
about where we are right now instead
people are relying more and more on
these supposed leaders in public health
and leaders in public health know their
job and that's to scare the living hell
out of you so you have joe biden putting
out statements about the painful
milestone of seven hundred thousand
american deaths from kovid quote just
another reminder of how important it is
to get vaccinated now remember biden is
never going to take any of the blame for
that astonishing death toll
even though
many many americans have died under the
auspices of the biden administration
it's not going to be that they blew it
in how they rolled this thing out or
their public health messaging
the idea here is just give us more power
to always give us more power anthony
fauci is a perfect example of this sort
of person
now if you listen to the show over the
course of the last couple of years what
you'll notice is that um i have shifted
my opinion somewhat on dr falchi so at
the beginning i thought okay this guy is
uh you know the head of the nia id under
the national institutes of health
and he seems you know fairly well
qualified to talk what he's talking
about and he seems like he wants to give
some facts
and even if he gets it wrong you know at
least he's trying and then over the
course of the pandemic it's become clear
that he's an openly political actor who
wants to maximize his own power
i i was not willing to say that up until
he started suggesting that you needed to
vax that you that that you still needed
to mask up after having had the vaccine
and then reversed himself when he
started mimicking every single message
of the biden administration well now i
mean it's clear that he never wants to
give up power anthony fauci was on your
television over the weekend telling you
that it might be too soon to tell if we
can get together for christmas
it is not too soon to tell if you can
get together for christmas you can get
together for christmas the reason i say
you get together for christmas is
because if you have been vaccinated then
you are not in serious risk of
hospitalization or death from covid when
i say serious risk i mean a risk higher
than the flu once you've been vaccinated
you are very unlikely to be hospitalized
or die
really really unlikely to die once
you've been vaccinated
okay and if you're unvaccinated you've
made that decision yourself and you do
not pose when they say that you pose a
massive risk to the vaccinated if you're
unvaccinated no the vaccine cuts that
risk
there is no guarantee in american
society that you will never get coveted
that is not a thing that we can never
guarantee because it is now endemic as
every major scientist has said
and anthony fauci because he is
power hungry and because so many people
seem to be wedded to the notion that
again government can solve all of your
problems because human beings are
malleable and government is just an
extension of that
i don't know why anyone would listen to
fouchy but he's still there talking
here's anthony thatcher over the weekend
saying it's too soon to tell if you can
get together with your family for
christmas
we can gather for christmas or it's just
too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got a concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not try to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time let's focus like a
laser on continuing to get those those
cases down and we can do it by people
getting vaccinated and also in the
situation where boosters are appropriate
to get people boosted
okay so he's saying we may not know by
christmas hey here's the reality most
people in most of the country are
already out and about and living their
lives as normal because either they're
vast or they're not vast and they've
made that decision
but fauci is so delusional at this point
that he's saying that he doesn't think
it's okay he said this this week he
doesn't think it's okay to get a mild
breakthrough illness from covet well i'm
sorry to tell you this but dr fouchy
cannot protect you from a mild
breakthrough almost from covid
you break through cases of covet are
significant
a very large person a very large number
of people who have been vaccinated
have gotten coveted and then they get a
cold or they get a mild flu and then
they're done
nobody cares about that sort of stuff
normally but if you believe that the
government is vested with this all inc
this incredible power to instill both
virtue and to and to protect you
then why wouldn't you listen to dr
anthony fauci when he says something
patently absurd here he is
it is an assumption
that is okay
to get infected and to get mild and
moderate disease as long as you don't
wind up in the hospital and die
and i have to be open and honest i
reject that
i think we should be preventing people
from getting sick
from covet even if they don't wind up in
the hospital
okay that's i'm sorry that's madness
that's madness that means that this is a
forever pandemic as i've been saying for
a while
this government wants the pandemic to
last forever
literally nowhere on earth is there a
guarantee that you won't get sick
that guarantee does not exist no mask is
going no masking regiment is going to
stop that unless we're all wearing n95s
for the rest of time
there's no point at which we ever go
back to normal under that rubric he's
aiming i mean that's him saying he's
aiming for zero covet no reputable
scientist believes zero covert is
possible it is not a thing and the
sooner we accept that the better off we
are but that's inherent that's accepting
our inherent
limitations as human beings and as a
society and that's something that too
many people are simply unwilling to do
except those limitations
which of course leads to some rather
fascistic top-down beliefs
by people like fauci right that mandates
are good
not just mandates on adult mandates on
children so fatu was asked about
california's new announcement that if
you're above the age of 12 you must be
vaccinated in order to go back to school
now again the number of kids who've died
between the ages of 12 and 18 is
extraordinarily low in the united states
because this disease thank god is not
extremely dangerous for small first for
people who are under the age of 18.
it is it is less dangerous over the
course of the last year more people have
died from pneumonia over the course of
the last year below the age of 18 in the
united states than have died from covet
and there are many more cases of cova
generally speaking than cases of
pneumonia in the united states but
here's anthony fauci very happy with the
vaccine mandate for children
the idea of getting vaccinated for
example getting children in school
vaccinated which is gone right now with
governor newsom in california things
like that are not new i mean there are
school situations where i know my own
children how to get vaccinated with a
variety of vaccines in order to be able
to go to school real quick there's
nothing new about that should other
states follow california's lead and
require kids to get vaccinated for the
coronavirus to go to school
you know i'm not going to be
recommending things to other states i'll
let the leaders of those states but i
think what the governor did in
california was something that was sound
judgment
again if you believe that government has
all powers and why not
what do rights matter i mean this how
fast she talks she talks about how
rights don't matter individual rights
are no longer of consequence and in the
end he ought to rule our benevolent
dictators ought to rule in a second
we'll get to our benevolent dictators
trying to figure out exactly how to
spend more of our money and encroach
more on our freedom first let's talk
about a simple fact if you own a
business you know there aren't enough
hours in a day to waste playing phone
tag the list of customers you need to
reach doesn't get any shorter especially
when business is good that's why local
businesses everywhere turn to podium
podium makes every interaction as easy
as sending a text so everything that
makes your business great can get done
faster podium isn't just a better way to
communicate it's a better way to do
everything it gathers reviews collects
payments even marketing to your
customers podium makes all of that as
easy as pressing send you're not going
to free up more time only you'll be
growing your business and getting more
done with podium you'll close deals with
customers before the competition even
has a chance to call them back join more
than 100 000 businesses that already use
podium to streamline their customer
interactions get started for free at
podium.com shapiro or sign up for a paid
podium account and get a free credit
card reader restrictions apply that is
podium.com shapiro go check them out
right now if you haven't been using the
power of text for your business you're
really really missing out i mean just
think about it yourself how many times
has a business called you and you just
let it go to voicemail because who's
gonna pick that up and then you know
your dentist will send you a text you
immediately text back confirming the
appointment text works podium knows it
let them help your business podium.com
shapiro to get started for free alrighty
we'll get to more in just one second
first if you're a video editor who has
dreamed of joining the daily wire team
at now is your big chance we are
searching for a new video editor to join
our post-production department in
nashville tennessee this person will cut
and assemble raw video footage using
compelling storytelling skills to
creatively support and emphasize subject
matter in videos for various daily wire
projects and shows like this one perhaps
a minimum of two years previous
professional video editing experience is
required for the opportunity this is a
nashville tennessee based position
to apply please submit your resume as
well as a link to your real or portfolio
through dailywire.com careers a full
list of our current openings of daily
wire can be found here as well
you are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
okay so when you carry forward this
vision which is that you have the
virtuous position and it doesn't matter
what democratic obstacles stand in your
way somebody needs to get out of the way
this takes you to some pretty
anti-democratic places and this has been
true again across the political aisle
but right now we are seeing it mostly
from people on the left so bernie
sanders for example over the weekend he
tweeted out two senators cannot be
allowed to defeat what 48 senators and
210 house members want we must stand
with the working families of our country
we must combat climate change we must
delay passing the infrastructure bill
until we pass a strong reconciliation
bill you know just focus in on those
stats for one second and we're talk
we're talking about anti-democratic
beliefs and norms it's not a surprise
that bernie sanders is fond of
anti-democratic norms after all he loves
the ussr and cuba but bernie sanders
tweeting out that two senators cannot be
allowed to defeat but 48 senators and
210 house members won
this boggles the mind a little bit
considering there are 100 senators
so if 48 senators want something this
would mean
just using a little quick math up top
here 100 minus 48 is 52 that means 52
senators do not want something so he is
saying that joe manchin and kristen
cinema if they don't want something
along with 50 other republicans they
should not be able to trump what 48
senators want
which is a weird notion of how
majorities work
he says they're not allowed to defeat
210 house members what those 210 house
members want now you'll recall there are
435 house members now again i may not be
on math quiz but 435 minus 210 is 225
which is larger than 210. so he's saying
a minority of the house and a minority
of the senate ought to rule
and of course he believes that because
he is privy to virtue
and the process can't be allowed to
stand in the way the process is of no
consequence at all
obviously and this attitude has
permeated down to the lowest levels of
the democratic activist wing
so nancy pelosi put out a notice
last week that they had extended the
thursday september 30th legislative day
to friday pushing back passage of the
bipartisan infrastructure framework and
to advance build back better but they
needed more time to reach their goal she
says quote more time is needed to reach
our goal of passing both bills which we
will it's about time
we all take great pride in the rescue
package
it's about time
there's an october 31st surface
transportation authorization deadline
after last night's passage of a critical
30-day extension we must pass biff well
before then the sooner the better to get
the jobs out there it's about time she
just keeps saying it's about time over
and over and over um if it were about
time then she would have passed a bill
last week she doesn't have the support
to pass the bill last week so instead
she's pushing it off until october 31st
she was supposed to vote on the
bipartisan infrastructure framework
right that that bipartisan
infrastructure bill
had support from republicans in the
senate it had support from republicans
in the house
she wasn't going to bring it up for a
vote however because there weren't
enough democrats in her own party to
pass it unanimously within her own party
and they were going to try and vote it
down
so she instead delayed it and she's
falling prey to the progressives who
again are a very small wing of the party
this caused kristen cinema to blast
fellow democrats she said canceling the
u.s house vote on the bipartisan
infrastructure investment and jobs act
denies americans millions of good-paying
new jobs and hurts everyday families
and she points out that it's the
radicals who are holding this up
she says congress was designed as a
place where representatives of americans
with valid and diverse views find
compromise and common ground that is why
when president biden asked me to
continue bipartisan infrastructure
negotiations i agreed and helped deliver
the bipartisan infrastructure investment
and jobs act a historic broadly popular
plan that reflects a key priority of
president bidens my commitment to
delivering lasting results is also why i
have engaged for months in direct good
faith negotiations over the separate
budget reconciliation proposal good
faith negotiations however require trust
over the course of this year democratic
leaders have made conflicting promises
that could not all be kept and have at
times pretended that differences of
opinion within our party did not exist
even when those disagreements were
repeatedly made clear directly and
publicly canceling the infrastructure
vote further erodes that trust more
importantly it betrays the trust the
american people have placed in their
elected leaders and denies our country
crucial investments to expand economic
opportunities it's like that's kirsten
cinema going hard after her own party
okay but what this means is that this
means christian cinema is the bad person
and kristin cinema is apparently
standing in the way of democracy and the
folks who believe that the federal
government should do anything and
everything
that any obstacle is an obstacle on the
road to utopia those people have no
limits
this is how you end up with video of
protesters following kristin cinema into
the bathroom at arizona state university
and berating her while she is on the can
i'm not kidding you this is a thing that
happened over the weekend now just
imagine for a second if republicans had
followed aoc into the bathroom and
berated her about the great new deal
right we would be treated to weeks on
end of talk about the innate horrors of
that
right aoc would be on tv crying and we
would have the media talking about how
all republicans were like this
meanwhile you have democrats who are
chasing christian cinema into a bathroom
where presumably she's doing her
business in order to harass her about
not voting for a 3.5 trillion dollar
boondoggle
and the media are kind of like
you know normal politics every day at
work here's a little bit of that video
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we we're not going forward we need
solutions in the buildback better plan
need has the solutions that we need
and bernie sanders of course is doubling
down on this as well so bernie sanders
was slamming kirsten cinema saying that
it's not the progressives holding this
up it's kirsten cinema and joe manchin
holding this up well no it's you
it's you i mean these are two separate
issues there's the bipartisan
infrastructure plan which again
has bipartisan approval and then there's
the reconciliation plan which needs to
be negotiated separately you guys tied
them together because
you wish to run roughshod over everyone
and that's why you're angry at cinema
because she's standing in the way of
your utopian schemes here's bernie
well i think senator cinema is is wrong
i think from day one jonathan it has
been clear president of the united
states has said it speaker of the house
pelosi has made it clear our majority
leader in the senate schumer has made it
clear both of these bills are going
forward in tandem we're not just taking
on or dealing with senators mansion or
senator cinema we're taking on the
entire ruling class of this country
it's the higher ruling class of this
country that needs to be taken on right
the language of virtue of pure virtue
democratic norms don't matter democracy
doesn't matter this guy thinks that 48
senators and 210 congress people are
enough to pass a 3.5 trillion dollar
bill what's the big deal after all what
they are doing is virtuous it all comes
down in the end to government power it's
all about government power
right and then
the powerful are entitled to completely
lie to you of course so cedric richmond
who's an advisor to president biden he
goes out on national tv and he keeps
repeating the lie that we don't have to
worry about the spending because of
course the number is zero
this is not about a number because at
the end of the day here's what's
important chuck the number is zero
we are paying for everything in this
piece of legislation and it's very
popular with the american people that
the
wealthy and big corporations finally pay
their fair share so we're going to pay
for everything we do
no you're not going to pay for
everything you do and you're lying to
the american people but you believe you
can get away with it because for too
long the american people have been
willing to grant absolute power to
whoever quote unquote agrees with them
depending on whether they have a d or an
r next to their name
and that needs to stop right now we need
to start thinking as an american people
systemically we need to start thinking
about the systems and incentive
structures we create for our politicians
this is not about electing the right
people it's not about getting rid of the
wrong people it's about making sure that
the checks and balances of american
government still work to protect the
fundamental freedoms
that
are there because human nature exists
and human nature is not trustworthy
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam scieventz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire
2021 an illegal alien harass is a us
senator in the women's bathroom dr fauci
tries to cancel christmas again and a
democrat lawmaker claims that efforts to
stop the killing of black babies
are rooted in white supremacy check it
out on the michael knoll show
[Music]